in just under four weeks students in the
clark county school district heading
back to the classroom but will there be
adequate staff to support the hundreds
of thousands of kids returning
kate houston dug into the numbers and
how the pandemic has impacted staffing
levels
i'm just happy to be back in the
classroom jamie anderson is preparing
for the upcoming school year at el
dorado high school where many teachers
are returning
but that's not the case across the
district you know this last year was a
really hard year on a lot of teachers
and
i know that a lot of teachers just said
i can't do this retired earlier you know
just quit
moved out of state whatever they they
did according to the ccsd career page
there are 814 teaching positions and 397
support jobs
needing to be filled i think we are
experiencing
the same challenge i think in the
private sector
where employers are trying to find
employees john valardita with the clark
county education association
says the district is normally
understaffed but the pandemic has added
unique challenges heading into this
school year
particularly you know with educators
trying to
reassess where their kids are where
their students are
to be able to effectively teach them
it's going to require more time so the
larger the class the much more difficult
and challenging will be
in addition to class size anderson says
the quality of instruction can suffer
then we have to start hiring you know
vacancy subs
and that just leads to more problems
down the road because these students
just aren't getting the education that
they deserve
moving forward anderson says the school
district needs to think of incentives to
bring more teachers in
and keep them here we all run as a unit
so when we don't have all the pieces in
place there's just there's pieces
missing and it just doesn't run as
well keith houston 8 news now right now
ccsd is recruiting for a variety of
positions including school nurses to
work at
a number of campuses in the valley there
will also be a bus driver
application session that is on july 20th
and 21st